Oh Oh
Guys Guys I'm so frustrated today For reasons I cannot see
What if I just take no I was gonna make a really bad joke.
I was gonna make a really bad joke.
It's not even a joke.
Oh gosh.
I just got back from Anime Expo!
Boy, are my arms tired.
Boy, are my arms tired from all the lifting I had to do?
um lifting your lifting all your tears she hates us did you
dodge the con flu i think so i think i'm good i don't feel
sick i just feel i feel ah i love backshot roulette Yeah,
I've never played this before, but I've seen lots of people
play, but I've never played it, so I'm excited to give it a
shot.
Ha ha, get it?
A shot.
Minto?
Wait, what?
I'm ready for rat jams and gamba.
Also, Vivikor, thanks for the five gifted.
Take up.
Thanks for the five gifted and ghost of mint.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
My voice echoing.
Does my voice echoing?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I think you have the window open two times.
Oh,
thanks for the five gifted andregals!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Dog strings, thanks for the five gifted!
Truly a doggy dog world.
Your echo...
You echo in my kokoro.
Yeah.
I think...
I think you might have heart disease.
If you have mint in your heart Or You have like a hole in
your lungs And when you eat mint, it goes to your heart Not
lungs Your Shoot, it's been a long time since I've been
human
Food doesn't go to your lungs, I think Your Your Your
Your...
Trachea?
I don't remember.
What's the pipe that goes to your stomach?
Esophagus?
The food pipe.
What do those look like outside of the body?
What is a trachea?
then.
Actually, I'm...
Suvi, thank you for the time gifted!
Thank you so much!
I'm usually a lurker, but I went to the Super Chat for the
first time on my birthday!
Oh my gosh.
Can I just call you AC?
Since I'm not sure how to say your old name.
Thank you so much!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
A-C-3X-0-D-I-N.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
So I'm catching up.
K-4, I think to the 10 gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Your regards to no spoiler rules on MGS streams, is that
applied to comments?
No.
I think you're good.
I think it's just on stream.
I don't think, do people, do you guys ever, like, look
through comments on video, on streams and stuff?
Like, after you, after, if you're watching Avad, do you look
through the comments, too?
Sometimes, yes?
You do?
I can't read.
Relatable?
Relatable, relatable, relatable, relatable.
Kiss your outro, thanks for the vibe, gift, damn, talk to
you.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Serval, thanks for the five gifted.
Ashen, thanks for the ten gifted.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, guys.
Had a ton of fun on virtual vacation.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, I hope you went.
You had fun.
It was so much fun for me.
Even though I was sent to the back rooms.
The back, the back, the back shot.
To the five gifted.
The, um, the, the backstage.
back rooms where we played the back shot roulette.
Katsu, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Delle, thanks for the 10 gifted.
It was fun.
Mint, no.
I'm going to shoot your Oshi.
Why are you guys blushing?
Virtual location was the most fun I've ever had at a
concert.
Please do it again next time.
AX.
Well, it's not really up to me, but maybe I could be a guest
at AX one day.
Heard you were going to be at Otaku-tan!
Yeah!
Oh, I need to add that to my menu of...
That's not what Backshot means.
That's the name of the game.
Oh, Buckshot.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh!
I got it mixed up
Guys, I think Guys, I got Bagshot and the Buckshot mixed up
I'm so sorry
Oh wait, hold on Let me do this one instead Let me do this
one I'm so sorry Because
They're very They're very What?
I got the, I got the back, I got the mixed up.
Everybody kept saying backshot for so long that I just, I
just, I just became the name of the game for me.
It was your guys in the comments in the chat that made me
confused.
In fact, in fact, I even, I almost put this.
as the as the thumbnail but it's the wrong one
it almost lines up
it shows up first at google images it does it actually does
i looked up i looked up back buck back buck shot roulette
roulette logo and it was the first thing that came up.
And now I'm very confused.
I'm not confused.
My brain is all mixed up.
I'm not taking the blame for this one.
I'm not, I don't, you can't, I'm not, I'm not taking the
blame for this one.
You can't, don't blame, you can't blame it.
I almost made...
I didn't even realize, though.
Gaslighting right at the beginning.
Good stuff.
Alright.
Anyway, I don't know anything about this game.
I don't know much of anything.
So I'm excited to see what happens.
And, um, hold on.
You are tired.
It's okay.
Thank you.
You don't even know its name.
I can't...
Just a Freudian slip.
But it's also just so close to the original name.
What is a buckshot anyway?
Pretty sure I've seen fan art of Mint playing buckshot
roulette anyway.
A shotgun shell.
Oh, okay.
Stop.
What is happening?
Why are you guys always telling?
Why are you guys always telling me to stop?
Stop reading every comment out loud.
What did you do?
What did I say wrong?
You should be on this raft.
It's true.
Don't stop.
I'm not reading, I'm not reading that comment.
I'm pressing X to DAO.
If you want a different type of game, I don't think YouTube
is the place for you.
Or Minto Channel.
Six bullets.
More than enough to...
Backshot!
Let's restart the stream at this point.
Oh, it's already starting so terribly!
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
You guys, let's just play the game.
I don't even know how to play.
My last super chat did not say buckshot.
Which one?
Oh my god, YouTube.
Now I'm getting confused.
You guys keep saying one word or the other.
them both at this rate.
I'm gonna have to ban both words.
So I'll never get confused again.
It's a bad, it's a, it's a, it's a, it's a word.
It's a canceled word on my stream.
Now, both of them.
The BA and the BU.
Monopoly Archive.
Anyway, um, yeah.
Buck shot roulette today.
It's dark.
That was audio, by the way.
I thought it was kinda loud earlier.
Oh, it's dark.
Oh, I'm afraid.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
AHH!
I'm at the club!
Oh, ho, bo, bo, bo, bo, bo.
Oh my god!
Oh, oh, oh, oh Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm at the club We're
partying online Yeah, yeah, yeah Oh, and that guy's smoking?
Okay, I thought that he had binoculars and was people
watching.
Do I have to talk to him?
Nope.
I don't think so.
Can I go to the club?
No, I have to go to the door.
Don't stop me!
Wow!
Oh.
Please sign.
Oh, hold on.
Please sign the waiver!
Okay, give me a second to, um, wait.
What waiver?
Don't read it, just sign it.
Yeah, but, um, I don't know what this is.
Why is there a waiver?
Anyway, okay, well, um.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm signing.
of liability.
The words are kind of hard to read, aren't they?
All of I waiver.
Can't see.
Me neither.
Okay.
I guess I'm gonna sign it anyway.
Oh, me too.
Oh, I put my fake name.
Mucho texto.
One live round.
Two blanks.
I insert the shells in an unknown order.
Oh.
Shooting yourself with a blank skips the dealer's turn.
How do I know if it's a blank?
One live, two blank.
You don't.
What if I shoot hit?
Oh, okay.
I either shoot me with it.
Hmm.
I'm shaking.
I'm so, I'm a little baby.
I'm gonna have, um...
Oh, wait.
baby oh your turn oh oh it shoots oh a dead now it's 50-50
you think i should shoot him what if i shoot him and it
doesn't work then he'll shoot me
All in, baby!
I got an achievement.
Successfully shoot yourself with 50-50 odds.
Anyway, bye-bye.
I win!
Oh, three live rounds.
Two blanks?
They enter the chamber in a hidden sequence.
Wait, three live two blanks.
Remember the basics of...
Who dat?
Who's Bayes?
Okay.
Three lives two blanks feels a little...
Aren't there, like, also other items you can use?
Where are those?
Okay.
Um, I'm shaking a little bit like a baby.
But I think I'm gonna take him.
Oh, later?
Okay.
I think I'm gonna shoot him.
Die!
Ah!
Mito wins!
Yeah!
Let's make this a little more interesting.
Two items each.
More items before every load.
I got... what is this?
A soda.
I got a magnifying glass?
Oh, a beer.
What live round one blank?
He's got handcuffs and what is that?
Okay, check the current round in the chamber.
Oh, well, it's 50-50.
Racks the shotgun ejects current shell.
Okay.
Oh, cigarette.
So if I look at this...
Oh!
What the hell?
Ah!
Is he gonna eat those?
Oh.
A little snack.
Oh, come on!
There was a little snack for him.
We knew that.
I think someone else also gave a fake name.
What is that?
Is that?
Two live rounds.
Two blanks.
Okay, dealer skips the next turn.
Oh, they also got the beer.
And then shotgun deals two damage.
Oh.
dealer skips the next turn so when do I use that?
Would I use that before?
Like I click on it and then I, well I guess I would have to
right?
you can use multiple items oh I'm scared so 2-2 hmm if I use
the 2 damage and I shoot myself is that uh is that an me
yeah you take the two down that'd be kind of silly hmm it's
50 50 basically it's like basically 50 50.
Chugging cuff baby It checks the current shell But I want to
do like all the damage then I'm gonna I'm gonna cuff him Hey
buddy And then
We'll save the beer for later You know what I am gonna I'm
gonna shoot him though Shoot Ah
Nice.
Always double down, V-Tuber.
Okay.
I'm gonna shoot me then.
I'm scared, though.
Beer clock?
Let me play the game, you guys.
Don't backseat.
Me!
Lady Luck is on my side, baby!
Now it's actually 50-50.
Now it's really 50-50.
Imagine if this was the only casino game she's lucky with.
How do you think I died?
Well, that means I'm not lucky at all.
If I try shooting him with the two-damp...
Well, I kind of want to use this only when I...
when I for sure know that I have it in there.
If I...
If I drink...
I'm gonna drink.
Oh!
Dang it!
I should abuse it on him!
Beer clock, baby!
His shackles...
Rip live.
I know, I thought maybe it would be a blank.
More beer!
I have a problem, I think.
Three live, two blank.
Don't love the overconfidence, but I love your laugh.
I'm gonna put away the knife at least.
Since we're not, we'll bring it out when I use it.
Chug baby!
No, I think I should shoot him.
I think I should shoot him.
No beer o'clock right now.
Yeah!
Oh,
he's gaming.
Wait a second, wait a second!
Very interesting.
He's gaming!
Don't shoot me!
Hey, dealer!
Wait, wait, wait a second, wait a second!
Oh my god!
Wait, I totally lost track of everything.
What is this?
Oh, these are the cigarettes!
I'm gonna eat them.
Three live round three blank.
Oh, okay, okay.
He went through the whole thing.
I'm gonna get a charge back.
Nice.
Three live, three.
Should I do the two damage?
If I get lucky, I can kill him.
I think.
I think I could try and kill him.
Oh, don't point it out yourself, though, man.
Don't point it out yourself.
Here we go.
Ah!
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no, the dealer's stupid!
No!
Okay, we're free.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, hold on.
Um.
He shot me twice and himself.
No, he shot himself once.
Me once.
It's a blank.
Are you sure?
Okay.
Oh, he drank one.
That's right.
You're right.
So me.
All right.
Let's grab some goodies.
Oh!
It's really pure clock right now.
Five live!
If
I use it, it doesn't waste my turn, right?
Oh,
it was a blank!
It was a blank!
Live.
But if the next one is also alive, You're up soon.
Thank you,
Line.
Thanks for going.
Alrighty.
I'm just gonna shoot him.
Oh, shit.
No!
Oh, no, I...
I didn't think I'd lose.
The final showdown.
Fibrillator, snowboard, blood transfusions.
No!
The dealer is so dumb!
What is that?
Oh.
What's happening?
Four items each.
No luck.
Peer skill.
Okay.
Yeah?
Wait, these don't even matter, though, right?
This is good, this is good.
Because they said no defibrillers.
You know the drill.
Oh, they do still matter?
It still works?
Oh.
Oh, and they matter until the cables are cut.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
He also has...
Oh, he has almost the same stuff as me.
He just got a beer instead.
I thought it was one hit kill.
Okay, I get it now.
Um.
I think I'm just gonna check though, honestly.
Oh!
Be do!
Nice.
And then it was one live, too blank, right?
Okay.
Use it on me, I dare you.
Oh, okay.
You're a little smarty in the pants, aren't you?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Be there.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh.
Oh!
Wait, so four and four, right?
Four live, four blank.
okay um i am once again checking
i'm scared though i should beard instead oh i don't think i
can put it back down it's okay though all
right and then i skipped his turn i don't know if i'm doing
this all in the right order but you know what whatever this
is good
Yeah, I figured the beer would be a waste if I knew what it
was.
Ah!
Okay.
Are you ready?
For what?
Oh,
his got cut.
Okay, so, hold on.
It was four and four.
I had one blank.
And two live.
Right?
So it's three and...
Wait.
Three and three now.
Okay.
One live with two damage?
Wait.
You're right.
Yes.
Oh yeah, you can see the shells on the table.
You're right.
So it is three and...
Okay, I'm going to do the beer.
Okay.
Hopefully it's not a live one.
Ah!
Just shoot him!
I might die though.
Uh oh.
I
think he's dumb.
I think he's dumb!
I think he's really stupid!
Minto wins by doing nothing!
What?
What did this mean?
I think I was dorks kicked too.
How was there were no more doors to kick?
He threw!
Double or nothing on- Double or nothing, first try!
But there goes all your luck for the year!
Oh no!
Thank you for that, AquaZuma.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, I left for five minutes.
What happened?
How did you win so quickly?
I don't know, I think I speedrun the game!
Let's try the double or nothing, right?
Do nothing, competition shoots itself in the face, what is
this strategy called?
Whoa!
Is this it?
Oh, this is just like the leaderboard stuff.
Oh, check the leaderboard.
Oh, what the?
I don't even know what these mean.
What are these numbers?
Are these like high school?
What does this mean?
Take the pills.
Where'd the pills are?
These ones?
Oh.
May impair your ability to drive.
Okay.
Consume the double or nothing pills.
Soap.
Our guy gone.
There's another door over there.
I think I could kick that one in if it let me over there.
Sometimes the music.
After you fire a blank you should swap your case for one of
the remaining cases
Deal, I, no deal!
Here we go.
Minto's ready.
Please sign the waiver.
how happy he is.
Binto!
I gave him a fake name.
What the heck is that?
Nice.
More medicine.
Two and two.
Adrenaline, steal an item and use it immediately.
I could take his magnifying glass.
50% chance to regain two charges, if not, lose one charge.
You guys, when it comes to, okay, when it comes to like
50-50 chance, I'm notoriously lost.
the 50-50 chance.
But you know, I'm gonna steal his glass.
Ah!
Uh, yoink!
Nice!
Get shot, Bozo!
Oh, he's probably gonna smoke his signal.
But he has to waste it.
I gripped you grab them with your these big old grippers
grab those
It was too alive one blank wasn't it
The odds were in his favor oh speaking of when I was on the
plane there and back I basically watched almost the whole
Hunger Games series.
I'm on the last movie, like halfway through the last movie.
Oh, oh yeah, it's two blank.
You're right, you're right.
It was two two.
How was it?
I've never watched it.
I really liked it.
I like could not stop watching them.
I was like, oh my gosh, I'm just gonna keep watching Hunger
Games.
I can see why so many people are obsessed with it.
I liked them.
All right, let's get some more goodies.
Yay, sacred birds!
Knife.
Yeah, adrenaline!
What'd you get?
I'm gonna take it.
Two blanks and one live.
What's that thing?
Wait, what is that?
What?
What is that thing?
Converts shells.
Inverts the current shell?
Wait, so if I use the magnifying glass, and if it's...
If it's a blank, I could use this and it'll turn it into a
live.
There's a blank!
I'm not afraid of that!
Yeah!
Okay, so now...
See ya, sucker!
You're scaring me today?
No, no, no, it's mine, it's fine.
Oh yeah, you got a little...
You're gonna eat those.
You got a little snack for you.
It's okay.
Wait, he could lose a life right now.
Ah!
Wait.
Oh no!
You son of a bitch.
What is that thing?
Okay, 50-50.
Actually 50-50.
actually 50-50 they replaced the dealer
it's a phone
I'm wondering if I should do the pills and maybe get two
what's the max I can have
oh four okay what you started with okay okay I'm gonna, I
think, um, I don't, I'll see what the phone does, but I'm
gonna smoke.
I don't want to do the, I'm not ready to take the 50-50
chance yet.
But I will take his handcuffs, but I also want to see what
the phone does.
I can hear everything.
The mysterious voice gives you insight from the future.
Yeah, but I'm just gonna take that.
Oh, I forgot that.
It makes you use it immediately.
Wait, so if I just...
If I shoot it at him, it doesn't really matter.
Oh, but do I want... Oh, well, I already wasted it.
It's fine.
Okay, okay.
Now we can use the... Actually, this is good.
This is good.
Because then, we use the knife.
Nice, nice, nice.
There we go.
Thank you!
I guess later...
Dayluck must be paying you back for years of screwing you
over.
Oh, there we go, everybody.
Give me some items.
What is that?
Oh, that's the phone.
The polarity.
Uh-oh, he can steal my stuff.
Okay, too live, too blank.
2-2.
I'm going to try to use the phone.
Second shell blank.
Oh, okay, damn, I think I said don't need that anymore.
So, if the second shell is blank, joy!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you, thank you!
Um...
I think I should shoot it.
Right?
The first shell is still unknown.
How many?
It was two and two, wasn't it?
Okay, I'm gonna shoot him.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Now we know this one is blank.
Hopefully he doesn't use it on himself.
Dang it!
He knew!
Wait, what
was that?
Oh, he just stole that!
Wait, why did you beat it up?
Wait a second.
Did that?
Careful now!
You guys
It all depends on what I get you guys Okay the polarity
Handcuffs The polarity Beer Handcuffs Four and four
He can steal my items and he can see I'm gonna handcuff him
First and foremost Yeah Yeah Smile when I handcuff you And
then I'm gonna I'm gonna beer it Beer a clock baby Eject It
was alive Okay so now we're at 4 and 3 Okay
if i ever had the opportunity to go to a con would you ever
that would deliver gifts would you be interested in a half
pound of honey i um would love honey but i don't think i
don't think i can accept um anything that's like food but i
appreciate it I just said a lot of gifting you a candle.
That I would love as well.
I go through candles like crazy.
I'm having to summon my friends, you know?
That's how you summon with a candle, the ghost, you know,
whatever.
I'll take the honey.
Oh.
Invert and bet.
You're right.
We could try.
But he's also gonna be handcuffed, so...
Ah!
It was live!
Wait a second, so that means...
Oh, I can't use the handcuffs again.
That means...
That means now there's only two live and four blank.
Oh my gosh.
Right?
Invert again?
Okay!
I'm telling you guys, if it comes to a 50-50 chance, it's
kind of hard for me.
Ah!
Beep beep!
Bean tokens!
Oh!
Yeah, take those off.
Give me some goodies.
Smokes.
Okay.
Yivvy!
Two and two.
Oh, he's also got a phone.
And a beer.
Second shell blank.
I think I'm gonna risk it.
I think I'm gonna shoot him.
Uh oh.
So that means the last two.
It's the last two, it's the last two, it's the last two,
it's the last two!
Kozu!
Thank you for the thank you!
Thank you!
Careful now.
Now we shoot.
Kaplawi!
No, you're like that.
What we got?
Steal.
Beer.
Three live for blank.
Oh.
Oh, he's got our...
Wait, I could steal.
It's probably better to steal the magnifying glass, right?
I'd rather not.
Thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Why is the audio all crackly?
I think, um, what should I, what order should I do?
Let's steal it first, and then beer it.
Steal it, wait, hold on, hold on, hold on.
It was three live, four blank, right?
Three live, four blank?
Three live, four, okay, thank you.
So if I do the beer first, I'm gonna do the beer first.
to get rid of something okay now it's three blank three live
adrenaline yeah give it to me yeah I can I can see
everything yeah yeah let's live yeah
Yippee!
Joy, thank you for the 50 gifts!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Mintzana, hi!
Oh, cancuffs, nice.
Cell phone, nice.
Four and four?
Four and four.
Okay, he's got the Smokesy's got the polarizer.
Fifth shell blank.
Wow, thanks.
Thanks a whole lot.
Thanks a lot.
Wait, okay, it was four and four.
Look at what bear clock is done to my Oshim.
4 and 4.
So you know it's 4 and 3 now.
So I guess we'll shoot.
Yeah!
Argentinian greets you from Argentina!
Hola!
Gracias!
Noam blue!
Okay.
Now it's...
Now it's 3.
And...
Three life, four blank.
Yes, yes.
He's gonna regain life.
He's gonna use a cigarette.
I think I'm just gonna shoot him.
I think I'm just gonna try.
Oh!
Yo!
Yippee!
I killed him!
What's happening?
Double or nothing?
I...
BANG!
More?
Nice.
Thank you for the Akusuba!
Alida!
I hope I said your name right.
Thank you!
Complim!
Okay.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I didn't see it.
Oh, 50-50!
50-50?
Okay.
Second shell live!
One to one.
One to
one.
And he has two steals!
He has two of them.
And a pack of cigarettes.
He's gonna heal himself.
Okay.
Cell phone.
Magnifying glass.
Steel!
Out of space.
How unfortunate.
No!
Alright, 2 and 2.
2 and 2.
Pick a door.
1, 2 or 3?
2!
Okay, okay, hold on.
Alright, two and two.
I'm gonna cuff him first.
I'm going to...
But I could end this.
Maybe I shouldn't have cuffed him.
You know what?
It's fine.
I just realized.
But it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay,
it's okay.
Just in case, just in case, just in case.
Just in case, something goes awry and I...
And then he heals, you know?
you could steal his adrenaline that is true actually if I
got it and then stole his other one he wouldn't be able to
use it at all and steal any of my stuff
I'd say steal his glass but then he can steal mine back
you can't steal a steal oh Wow.
Yeah, let's steal his glass then.
So we can't use it.
Yeah.
And then we'll just take him out.
I'm going to lose my items right here, right?
Aren't I?
Or do I get to keep them?
What's wrong, Mr. Dealer?
Pinto weens!
Second round.
Alright.
Yeah, see we lost everything anyway.
Handcuffs.
Medicine.
Beer.
Oh.
Three.
Oh, four and four.
Four and four.
Cuff them.
Pretty little dainty hounds.
here and oh okay so now it's four and three four blank three
live i'm
gonna do another one
i just made it okay back
to 50-50
I'm scared if I I think I might use it on myself because
then I will then it will it will skip him I'll be able to
use it again because I don't want him to handcuff me and be
able to like you know he's got a lot of stuff he's got a lot
of stuff I think I'm gonna I think I'm gonna go for me drugs
first no No, why would I use that?
Ah!
Medicaid for the gamble.
No, that makes sense.
I didn't lose anything before.
Okay, so now it's three blank two live.
Pills.
This might be dumb.
Uh.
GG, everybody.
Dealer!
What?
You're gonna take my pills?
Just take off.
Dang.
Thank you for reading my message.
Thank you.
The $10.
You win some, you lose some.
Dang it.
Alright, let's...
Do I do this one again?
Consume the pills?
Pills, time.
Whoa.
I'm feeling a little woozy.
The pills...
Wow!
The pills are hitting!
Let's go!
Oh, God!
No!
Sign any waiver!
Just give it to me!
Put your name!
Uh...
Minto!
Enter!
Yeah!
I'm ready.
Give me the goods!
Give me the...
Oh, yeah.
Sweet, sweet knife.
Yes.
Yes!
A phone!
Three and three!
Look how happy he is!
Just like me!
He knows the game, he knows the game!
Mooshy mooshy!
Fifth shot!
Why you must tell me useless information!
Hold on, I'm doing girl math.
So, if he...
Wait, okay, no.
Sorry, sound like a father figure.
3-3-5th blank.
So, it's...
No, it said fifth is the live round, didn't it?
Fifth is the live round.
I'm just gonna shoot myself.
Yeah, that's the name of the game!
Yeah!
Hold on, now it's one blank, or rather two blank, three
live, but we know the fifth one is a blank, or no, it's
live.
Yeah, I think I am going to knife it.
You know, my grandma used to, there was a guy when my
grandma used to live in like the old people's home, and
there was a guy that used to bother, that used to bother
her.
And she would always tell him, she was just like, if you
don't cut it out, if you don't, if you don't leave me alone,
my, she was talking about my grandpa.
She was like, my husband's up there, and he's filing his
teeth down to a point, and he's got to rip your throat out.
My grandpa only ever made soup.
Anyway, shoot the dealer.
Yeah!
Oh no, he's got the cigarettes though.
Okay, so one blank.
That was the second round.
This is the third one.
What?
The thrill of knowing.
Yeah, very interesting, huh?
What are you gonna do with that information?
Oh!
This is the fourth one?
Yeah, bring me back to life!
But this is the fifth one, right?
This is the fifth round?
So I should...
File it out, baby!
Eat this!
The thrill of the pills.
I mean, the shot.
The buck shot.
Sorry to wear down.
Where am I?
I kind of call my mom.
The polarities.
Whoa, wait.
You're up.
Quick.
Oh, ma'am.
Oh.
Welcome back, Minto.
Did you notice the BTD plushie?
BTD?
What?
Bloons?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, what was it?
You guys?
Don't donate when I'm trying!
Like the TV model.
Oh, 1-1?
Oh, okay, okay.
1-1.
Second shell blank.
Awesome.
He's probably gonna win that, though.
Oh, well.
Bloodthirsty Minto even.
I got those two.
Quick math.
That's all it is.
You asshole!
What are you stealing from me?
Not my smokes!
He took my medicine.
And he's taking even more medicine.
Lose the 50-50.
He never loses.
What a jerk.
Cuffs.
Nice.
One and one again.
Your grandma.
Get him, grandpa.
Yank his throat out.
Your grandpa.
I made cream of mushroom and corn soup.
Basically.
I'm getting...
I can steal his...
I'm thinking either his phone or his handcuffs
If we steal the phone we'll know exactly what is what But
he's just gonna reheal, you know I don't even have a saw
How many shells?
Just two and it's 50-50 Well, yeah, but of course it would
be So one live, one blank
I think I will steal the handcuffs
I see it all Oh yeah, you can't steal the adrenaline I see
every Oh, wait
There's a time limit
What?
There's a time limit I
don't even know what to do
shoot him well like i did handcuff him so you're right nice
i
messed up i messed up i pressed escape email pressed escape
i think wait is it hold escape to exit the game or i can't
tell if i'm gonna exit the gate i think it's hold escape to
exit the game you guys i think it's i think it's hold escape
to exit the game
Ah!
Okay, magnifying glass.
Oh!
I won't mess it up this time.
Oh, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50, 50!
Second shell blank!
Okay, second shell blank.
So, um, handcuff him.
So what we're gonna do is we'll shoot him And then I'll
invert the polarity
We got it, we got it this time I messed up a little bit last
time But we're fixing it this time We're fixing it this time
What's wrong, dealer?
Who's that?
What?
That's not my name.
Who is that?
Phone.
Polarity.
Steel.
You were under the influence.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
Three and two.
Three blank two live.
Third shell blank.
Sounds like you drew a bad scrabble hand.
Love life.
Now it's 50-50.
But I cuffed him, so I think I should just shoot him.
Wait.
Did it say the third one was blank or li- Oh crap.
Now I can't remember.
Third is blank.
Okay, okay.
So this one...
And it's...
Okay, so now it's 50-50.
So now it's 2-2.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh, this one's...
Wait, okay, hold on.
We can get a for sure shot in.
We can get a for sure shot in if...
The second...
Let's be honest, those ones are probably live.
Right?
This one- this next one is probably live.
If I invert it to blank and shoot myself and then go again,
but I invert it to live,
then...
I could get it, you know?
Let's try it.
And if I, you know, shoot it...
Oh, see, see, see, see, see?
Ah!
Minto gaming.
There we go.
Oh, I forgot he had those.
Lose, lose, lose.
Why don't you ever lose?
Yeah, dummy!
Wait.
Now, how many is left?
There's only two things here.
Only live.
left?
Why don't sometimes the things show up?
Sometimes they're on the table, sometimes they're not.
It's so confusing.
You know what, it's whatever.
Yippee!
Get me more stuff!
Handcuffs?
Phone?
Knife?
Handcuffs?
Nice.
Pills here?
50-50!
I wish I had the knife though.
Oh, I do have it?
I wish I had an inverter then.
Second shell live.
Cuffs?
No, no.
We'll save those.
He doesn't even have anything to heal himself.
So...
Nice.
Okay, we get more stuff.
Ooh!
Steel!
Oh, beer.
Knife.
Okay.
Oh, we gotta use everything.
Okay, two and two.
Two and two.
First, I'm gonna
Then I'm gonna phone.
Third shell live.
Okay, third shell is live.
Actually, you know what?
What if I just did this?
Ta-ah!
We know, we know, we know, we know everything!
Oh!
I didn't realize I killed him.
Femi Kaur, thanks for the five gift.
Oh!
Double or nothing!
Nice shot, boys.
Thank you.
No!
All in, baby!
All in, all in.
Reset the table.
Oh, never mind.
Just kidding.
Don't reset the table.
Ah!
No!
My magnifying glass!
So unfair!
Pyromonics are the 20!
Thank you so much!
Shit, it was too fast.
What was it?
You guys!
Help me, please!
Oh, three and three.
Okay, okay, okay.
Three and three.
Kaffum.
Cuff'em, baby.
Clear o'clock.
Oh, that was a blank.
So now it's three live two blank.
Spam the beers, I know, right?
True.
Actually, I was thinking of doing it anyway.
It might be...
Now it's...
It's two and two again.
It's two and two.
Let's do it too
I was thinking spam the beers too because I'm thirsty Oh Oh
he's cuffed you're right He is cuffed I forgot
I think I'm actually gonna do a polarity change
Okay I think I'm going to do the polarity change.
He has the cigarettes to heal himself.
Why?
Just cause.
Ah.
What we got?
It's fine, though.
It's fine.
So now it's one live tool.
Blank.
Watching a little before my flight back home.
Hashes, have a safe flight!
Invert again?
Oh, true, true.
Will invert it?
Yeah, true, true.
Invert it and then knife it.
If this doesn't work, I'm just hella lucky.
I mean, unlucky.
Good.
three and three it was a good stride thanks three and three
Looking at what he has too.
Hmm.
Just kick talk on the membership.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Three and three, right?
I think I'm going to kick out two of them with the beer and
then use the glasses.
The magnifying glasses.
Because
the lower the lower we have it was three and three right
okay that was a blank it's three and three
okay now it's two and two now it's two and two so let's do
the phone first i mean doesn't really matter okay fourth
shell is live and now we'll know the whole the whole image
basically almost oh blank okay okay okay so the fourth one
was live right so let's do this on me
okay now magnifying glass again
blank so the last two oh shoot there's no way that i can
there's no way i can avoid it There's no way I can avoid it!
No!
And he's gonna get...
He's gonna probably take down two!
No!
Love the TV model.
Thank you!
Thanks, B-E-C-R.
Thank you so much.
Maybe he'll take himself.
True, true, true, maybe.
I don't think so, though.
He'll probably use a magnifying glass or something.
Sorry that the music sometimes gets a little crackly.
I don't know why.
I knew it!
He's getting a snack.
You jerk.
Careful now.
Oh, I didn't eat cuff.
That's a good question.
Oh, because I will.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Dan, thanks for the towadi.
Thank you so much.
Three live four blank.
Okay.
You guys, I don't think I should take the 50-50 chance,
right?
I shouldn't take the 50-50 chance, right?
Six first.
But it was only...
I...
I think But two charges with But it only goes up to three
Yolo I hate this afterlife
He never loses But I always lose Gozu Thank you for the 10
Thank you so much Thank you so much
I wish this was live.
Now it's 3 and 3, right?
I'm just gonna shoot him.
I'm just gonna die anyway.
Just shoot!
That's right.
Shoot again!
No way.
Okay.
Three blanks in a...
No, wait.
Or two blanks in a row?
It's over.
Why can't I ever win the money?
I would have lived if I had...
Oh, wait.
No, I wouldn't have lived because he did the knife too.
The disrespect of the sawed off.
I know, right?
Such bad RNG.
Okay, third time's the charm, everybody.
Third time's the charm.
Oh.
I'm feeling it.
The
system is down.
The system is down.
.
I'm gonna pick someone from chat.
Can win the money?
Here, take mine.
Okay.
We'll name it after you, Blade.
Thank you for your sacrifice.
Welcome to the 73rd Hunger Games.
You volunteered.
They'll keep you alive, don't worry.
We'll split the money like 30-70.
Okay, Blade, you got this.
Oh, 4-in-4.
Look how happy he is.
Okay.
Um, four and four?
No pressure, Blade.
Rip Blade.
We barely knew you.
Now it's three, four, yeah.
Ah!
Sorry, catch the way all that hum.
I think I should just shoot again, but I want to use the
knife.
No, it's not worth it.
He's going to heal.
There it is.
So now it's 2 and...
Wait, 3 and 3, right?
Very interesting.
This guy, he kind of looks like a creepypasta version.
Oh.
He kind of looks like a creepypasta version of Jack
Skellington.
I used to watch that movie every day as a kid.
So much so that my mom had to be like, Mint, you can't watch
the nightmare before Christmas anymore.
I'm sick of it.
I ate the cigarettes.
So what?
It's now...
Two live, three blank.
Yadmore, I'm trying to sleep.
You didn't even have to tell me.
Unbelievably hot bread.
I literally would watch it every single day.
I would watch Nightmare Before Christmas.
Every day as a kid.
My mom was like, there are other movies.
Eventually, eventually I cut it down to every other day.
And then every other day that was a nightmare before
Christmas, I watched Alice in Wonderland.
Oh, no.
But my sister also wanted to watch Alice in Wonderland with
me.
So we would watch it together every other day.
than I'd watch Nightmare Before Christmas.
Which version of Alice in Wonderland?
The Disney animated one.
Ouch.
Oh.
Okay, wait.
What is it?
Oh, shoot.
It's two live, three blank, right?
Should I risk it for the biscuit?
Oh!
Two blank, two live!
Hyper fixating from day one.
Pretty much.
He's got pills, but...
I mean, I know he's gonna win it, but who cares?
I've got nothing to lose.
Only Blade has to lose.
Uh-oh.
Now it's two live.
One blank.
Wait, now it's 50-50, right?
Wait.
Now it's 2-live!
Oh my gosh.
So we're both gonna get hit.
Idiot!
What if he turns it on himself, though?
He could.
The dealer doesn't always make a great deal.
50-50.
50.
Ah!
He lost!
Dang it!
Why'd you have to be smart?
Okay.
Wow, I can't believe he can actually lose the 50-50.
It's only when I do it that I lose every time.
Beer.
Magnifying glass.
Polarizer.
Nice.
Two lives.
Three blank.
All right.
Two live, three blank.
Peep-boop-peep-peep-a-peep-a-peep-a.
Second shell blank.
I should have used the beer first.
I'm an idiot.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
So the second one is blank, isn't?
And then, let's use the glass.
Okay.
Because if it's blank...
Oh, it's live!
The less bullets we have, you guys.
He has handcuffs.
The less bullets we have, the better.
Yippee!
Good job, Blade!
I told you!
See?
I can brain.
sometimes.
Oh!
Nice.
What are we stealing, boys?
Three and four.
Okay.
Wait, what's behind his beer?
What's behind the beer?
I guess we're gonna figure it out now.
Oh, it's an adrenaline thingy!
Oh!
It was, uh, four.
It was three live and four blank, right?
Now it's two fuller.
It's just one?
No way.
Oh my god.
Don't do it.
How many was that?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Now you can't, you guys, you can't steal the adrenaline,
so...
he knows the house always wins three blanks in a row so
messed up but this is this is still a blank so it was two I
inverted one well I wait oh I'm wait
I can't keep track thanks guys for helping me
nice nice Wish I could steal his adrenaline, though.
Alright, let's get some more stuff.
Some more goodies.
Some beer.
Some smokes.
Wow, he's really...
This is so hospitable.
He's such a host.
Medicine.
3 live 4 blank.
I mean, to camp math.
Not when it's like that.
When I use the inverters, it makes me all...
We were at 4 health, so I'm actually going to use it.
I'm going to have a little snack.
Yeah, okay, good, good, good.
Okay.
It was 3 blank.
No, sorry.
4 blank.
3 live.
Aha!
No, I said the wrong thing.
Right?
Or blank.
Now it's 3.
Now it's 3-3.
Whatever.
It's 3-3.
Now it's 3-3.
I will cuff him.
Just so I remember to do that.
Take that.
And we're going to take his...
We're going to take his magnifying glass.
I don't know why I'm still shaking.
I know what it is.
So now it's 3-2.
Might as well.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
2-1.
What the heck?
I can't even use it.
Oh, he is going to use it.
Lose the 50-50.
Yes, yes, yes.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
It's okay.
We still have three left.
And then this one's the blank.
Oh, no, wait.
Actually.
Now this one's the blank, isn't it?
This one's the blank.
Oh, Bruna!
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, hello.
We're just gambling.
I think we're...
Well, we're fighting for one of my viewers' lives.
He was so graciously volunteered.
Steel.
Ray Mack, thank you for the five you did.
Goffs.
All right.
Two blank, one live.
Whoa!
Murphy, thanks for the story!
Okie dokie.
It was two blank, one live.
Now this could have...
Either give us a 50-50 chance or...
Third shell...
I was hoping you would tell me where the live one was!
But he's cuffed so I can do both.
Actually, actually this kind of works because he only has
one life left.
And we know that what, the first or the second...
Are blank.
I mean, one's live and one's blank, so it's buffed.
Yeah!
Three.
Oh my gosh.
Medicine.
Smokes.
Two?
Four blank three live.
Oh gosh.
I hate this stupid ass phone.
No wonder I break it every time.
The seventh is alive.
So, okay.
So that means...
Oh gosh.
2, 4.
Yeah.
So might as well.
Okay, this is 1.
Uh-oh.
I think we're in trouble.
The 6!
No, you guys, we- I can't- it won't give me anymore!
We only have 2 lives each!
Oh!
He got rid of one of the live.
Oh gosh.
I don't know how many we're at.
I think...
Blade.
Blade, we got played.
Blade!
How did he die?
Man.
No!
Blade is a ghost now.
Blade is a wisp, real.
Next viewer.
Alright.
Rip Blade.
The system is down.
Please sign the way we're okay.
Made Blade.
Oh, Shady!
What perfect timing.
Thank you.
Welcome, everybody, to the 74th Hunger Games!
Okay, what do we got?
A little knife, a little beer, a second beer, some
handcuffs.
Don't drink and have a knife at the same time!
The real shady.
Three and three, baby.
Three and two, baby.
Two and two, baby!
Haven't seen him.
I may take those many buckshots since I cleared my brow.
Jail.
That's you.
You know what?
This one's also for you.
Don't we risk it for the biscuit?
It's one to one life to blank.
Risk it?
I don't think you can win the odds of not being in your
favor.
Oh, shoot.
I thought he had one more.
Oops.
I thought he had a...
I thought...
It's a...
My bad.
Three and four.
I swear...
Nope, nope, nope.
Wait, what did I just eject?
No, no, no, no, no!
Yo!
You, uh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stop!
No!
You'll never get me.
You'll never.
You will never.
Ever.
Ever, ever, ever, ever.
Ever get me.
I will not let you have that victory.
I will not let you have me ever you you will never be able
to brag about that ever you will you will you you will never
catch me saying your name ever got
your nose
Okay.
And you're like, challenge accepted.
Mm-hmm.
Thanks, Ice.
Uh.
I'm completely lost in the sauce.
I have no idea where we're at.
Oh, 3-3.
Thank you for the time.
So now it's two live three blank, right?
Give it to me.
It hurts so good!
I hate this damn foam.
Should have stolen the cuffs.
Well, that's fine.
Um, it's fine.
Uh.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Sure.
Oh!
Oh, you!
You, asshole!
You!
thank you shady for your sacrifice yeah we got outplayed
that was my bad i should have got grabbed the cuffs sorry
shady i killed you oh my god what's wrong with you guys
today i'm gone for like three days and you all become
craziness maybe we're taking too many pills or maybe I need
to take the pills!
I don't know anymore!
Please sign the waiver.
Thanks for the pink, though.
I think we missed you.
Alrighty, who am I?
Oh, Star Creator!
How perfect!
I'd volunteer as trivia, but my name doesn't fit.
No problem, 10 out of 10 would be me shield again.
Let's see.
I think we can make it fit.
Star Creator...
St- Storr- Stor-quit Stor-Crt!
Stor-Stor-C-R-T!
Stor-C-R-T!
Stor-Quit!
Bing!
2 and 2, Berry.
Hmm.
Not really much telling here.
It's really just it's just
I appreciate not seeming so weird in comparison.
There's always going to be someone weirder than you out
there, you know?
Fair game of roulette.
Truly.
Alright, let's eat it.
Ah!
Oh god, we really hate it.
We really hate it!
Oh.
What are you doing to that?
What do you mean by that?
Wait, what are you doing to that?
Ah!
so now it's oh wait hold on it was what was it two and two
and then i ate one and then uh i got shot oh it's two blanks
No, it's not.
I don't think it's... I don't think it's two blanks.
Wait.
He inverted one.
He inverted a blank.
Yes.
So now it's one one, right?
It's one, one.
Ready to chance that 50-50.
I think I'm gonna eat it.
Because regardless, I'll get the next shot in, right?
If I eat the shot, Wait.
Oh wait, shooting yourself with a blank skips the dealer's
turn.
Um.
Oh.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
If you invert, you will either do damage or he won't do
damage.
True, true, true, true.
On himself.
well that was ended a little anti-climactically now didn't
it
more nice two and three
take that and that and put that and i'm gonna take a A
little smoke break.
A little snack break.
Pester Mike!
Welcome to Bambusha Planku!
And, uh...
There you go.
Now it's one to three.
You okay, buddy?
We're gonna risk it.
Ah!
two one one live two blank oh gosh oh gosh wait he might
risk it too
wait he's probably gonna steal my pills he's gonna steal my
pill probably wait why are you doing that you just saw what
was in there oh oh
Now it's blank, isn't it?
But it's blank, though.
Why didn't you...
Okay.
Now it's out.
Give me stuff.
smokes magnifying glass.
Oh, that's it?
Okay.
He got two magnifying glasses!
Two and two!
But...
Two and two.
I'm gonna smoke just in case.
Bing!
And I'm going to...
See what it is.
Blank.
Okay, we're just gonna have to...
We're gonna have to hope, you guys.
We're gonna have to hope.
Shoot.
I should have used the meds.
Oh, never mind!
Yippee!
66% It's not good.
It's not high enough for me.
Good job, Stark Greater.
Second round.
Okay.
Two and two.
Two and one.
Second shell live.
So this is...
Oh, wait.
Actually, I'm confused.
When I use the beer, does it...
Or rather, when I use the phone, does it count...
Would this be the second one then?
Right?
So this is the second one.
What?
Wait!
It's not!
It counts from your current round!
Oh my god!
Well, that was a good experience.
At least we know now.
Good to exp- oh shoot.
Uh oh.
What are you stealing?
No!
Mayoshi can't count.
What are you talking about?
It has nothing to do with counting.
Oh.
But now this one is blank.
It was two and two, right?
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
It was empty.
Oh.
What?
Three live four blanks.
How about that counting?
Shut up.
Okay.
I wish I had handcuffs though.
Yeah, let's steal the glass.
Even though he could steal it right back if he wanted to.
Actually, no.
Wait.
Sorry.
I can have handcuffs if I want to
Now it's 3 and 3 right 3 and 3
Now I'm gonna steal his glass
I was like I was like I'm gonna steal his Oh it's live I was
like I'm gonna steal his glass And then I was like wait a
second No he has handcuffs Shoot baby shoot
Okay.
Interesting.
What's he gonna do?
Careful now.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I'll be honest.
Star Creator, I'm sorry.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
I don't think we're gonna make it, man.
Wait a second.
I can just get rid of all of these.
I can just get rid of all these, can't I?
Then maybe we can get a health item.
Because we'll get through the rest of the bullets.
There we go.
Knife.
cigarettes cigarettes please cigarettes please
okay how do I want to play this okay wait hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
on I'm strategizing I'm gonna I'm going to try and explain
my thought process i'm not looking at chat because it it
distracts me wait hold on i don't want to lose my thought i
don't want to lose my train of thought if i beer it and get
rid of one
and see what it is and then i depending you know if it's if
we get rid of the blank and for the we could just saw it and
then um and then kill him but if it's the blank i can steal
his his polarizer and then make it live and then kill him so
either way either way it works why does she overcomplicate
things why are you rude wait what did I just get rid of god
damn it you know what fuck you man don't be mean to me like
that why can't I have my own my own thought process I
got rid of the blank oh okay thanks guys
it wasn't overcomplicating
it's just a different way of thinking
That's it.
Actually, those are two really good ones I get, I think.
Three and three.
I'm just gonna use both of them, honestly.
Oh.
Two, three.
Two, three, two, three.
My...
Well, you're doing great using that big noggin of yours.
Thanks, Turtles.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm a little sensitive.
today because I'm not feeling so well, so.
Might as well.
Oh!
Now it's one three.
What are you gonna do, mister?
Now one, two.
Who is gonna chest?
Oh!
Uh-oh.
No!
Not on me!
Ew, jerk!
Give me the...
Wait.
Oh wait.
Oh, it's just a black... Wait.
I thought he... I thought he did the last one.
Fallen.
Two and two.
Oh, he bearded it, that's right.
Now that we know that it's of our...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
One and two.
Now that we know that the phone works for our current round,
this will help, you know.
Third shell blank.
Otherwise, I'm dead otherwise.
If I don't use this.
Come on, 50-50!
Ah!
Oh, wait!
Oh!
It worked!
Yeah!
Let's try it.
You don't- what are you dumb?
You don't even need to look!
But it's a good thing that I took the medicine.
It's a good thing I took the medicine.
You asshole!
Then this is the one that's a blank, right?
This is the blank one.
Oh my goodness.
Four and four!
I don't know what...
Yeah, I think I'm gonna steal the cuffs.
I hear everything.
Four and four.
I'm wondering if I should polarize, like if I should invert
one of them, you know?
I don't know.
I'll start praying.
Nice, nice, nice!
You got this minute, show them what a true gambler can do.
Okay!
Now I'm going to invert it.
I'm scared!
Just go!
Star Creator, you lucky bastard!
Yubi!
Oh.
$10, double or nothing!
Five bucks to put on the horses.
I don't even realize there was money down here until...
We're always double or nothing.
Wait, he still gets to keep his phone?
That's messed up.
That's actually kind of messed up.
Three live, four blank.
Oh, he has...
He has two.
Three live, four blank.
Two live, four blank.
Two live, three blank.
He can really...
He can hurt me really badly with what he's got.
I'm kind of scared.
She doesn't have any health, so I will take it.
Okay.
Otherwise, I was thinking of maybe possibly inverting it and
using it on myself.
This too was deal or no deal.
What are you taking?
No!
Uh oh.
So it was a blank, huh?
Wait.
I hate this guy.
I hate this guy so much.
so that was also a blank turn so now it's two and two right
i knew
it i knew i knew i knew i knew
The house is cheating!
I'm sorry.
What is that?
Trash can?
No, we're not throwing out your body.
Why would we throw you out?
Ah, thanks for the raid.
Oh, Dizzy!
Thanks for the raid!
Oh, oh, oh.
I did not just lose.
One of my viewers, Stark Creator, just lost.
Oh, it was an urn!
But you got to the end.
You made it.
Verily, thanks for the five, Grypton.
Imagine the last thing you show before you die being the
house is cheating.
Okay, guys, thank you for the five gifted.
Yeah.
What is Mint doing in a dirty restroom?
You know!
Dirty things.
I'm dirty, Dan.
You know.
I haunt this.
This is the maid's cafe, actually.
This is...
I'm taking pills.
Hold on, here we go.
Here we go.
Are you guys ready to feel it?
Are you ready to feel it?
Hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I'm feeling
it.
Let's go!
Signed a waiver.
I'll sign anything.
I'll sign anything you give me.
I'll do it.
See, too, thank you for the five gifted.
Hold on.
Who else?
Uh, brr.
Johnny, thanks for the five, gifted!
Mr. Albusy, thanks for the 10, gifted!
Ow, thanks for the five!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
Karma strikes!
Wait.
I hope I spelled your name right.
Here's some spending money.
Don't blow your brains out.
Uh...
There we go, baby.
Two and two.
Uh.
All right.
I'm going to steal their cuffs.
Yoink.
And I'm going to check the phone.
Fourth shell blank.
You don't say.
I'm just gonna shoot.
Ah!
Let's go!
And now it's 50-50.
I don't want him to steal my polarizer, so I'm gonna use it!
Yeah!
Uh-oh, wait.
Now it's one live and one blank.
Okay, wait.
He just got rid of the live one.
Yes!
Now it's blank.
He doesn't know that.
Oh, yes, he does.
Knife.
Can't have so.
Okay.
Three live for blank.
Of course, he knows he's cheating.
I know, right?
What was it?
Three, three, nine, four, blank.
Okay, um, hmm, what do I want to steal?
Hmm, I have handcuffs, handcuffs, but he does not.
Yes.
Steal the glass.
Blank.
Uh, okay, it's blue.
Blank?
Let's open it a little.
Since I have...
Well, I was going to say since I have two, but he only has
one live.
Wait, what is it now?
So it's 3-3 now.
Right?
Two live.
Or, yeah.
No, it's 3 live, 4-blank, yeah.
And so now it's 3-3.
Um...
I'm trying to think if I should steal his beer or not.
I ash ash ash I'll believe in you.
Thank you.
It's 50-50 right now.
Even if I steal the beer, it's not going to change anything.
Well, I guess it would maybe if we want to shoot if we want
to use it on ourselves or not you know
i'm deciding i'm deciding i think i will
i see it all this is for you karma important what happened
Oh, shoot.
I should have just used it.
Wait a second.
Wait.
Take the meds?
Yeah, I'll take the meds.
Win the 50-50!
50!
I'm actually tripling.
Oh, yeah.
Goodbye, karma.
How does that Taylor Swift song go?
Karma is a god.
Karma is...
What?
Wait, what?
How?
How did we?
How did we win?
Four and three.
Okay.
We're just gonna do that.
Please be live.
Blank.
It's okay.
Actually, he does have medicine, so...
I'm just gonna...
Okay, now it's 3-in-3.
3-in-3.
He's got...
Pretty decent stuff over there.
To know the future.
Song, go for it.
Yep.
I think so.
What the?
Wait, what?
Sorry, my chat just...
What?
I can use now YTC filter on the back end!
Hold on.
I can't reach out anymore because of the...
Wait, what?
It just updated!
What?
That's crazy!
Yeah, new update.
It just appeared out of nowhere!
Oh my gosh!
I'll have to put in all my presets and stuff.
Later.
Okay, did I shoot yet?
I sawed it off.
Okay, here we go.
Let's hope for the best.
Yep, that sounds about right.
I can see you guys now.
No worries.
Oh, karma.
Karma is the cat sitting on my lap.
Karma is the breeze in my hair.
Oh, what?
You got rid of the...
Wait, why did you do that, you dummy?
But that's it, right?
Yeah.
We lived.
Yes, he didn't have two saws, just like we did.
And fumble them both.
You know.
Oh, three and three.
Surely the pills will save us.
Yeah.
We won't lose the 50-50 three times in a row.
What was it?
Three and three.
Three and three, right?
Okay.
Maybe I should have, uh...
Actually, maybe I should have checked it first.
And then inverted it.
You know what?
No, it doesn't matter.
I think we're pretty dead.
Doesn't matter, you guys.
It doesn't matter.
Oh.
Oh, he can take my thing.
Oh, he can...
Unless he really throws.
from anime expo how was your trip it was great oh karma is
the breeze in my head karma is the cat that sleeps on me
karma is a bit i
feel like i'm in the bathroom from silent hill
goodbye karma thank you gg Alright, LG, you guys, we gotta
make this one count.
We gotta make this one count.
We gotta...
Minus three viewers.
This next person will be the one!
I'm not gonna take the... I'm not gonna be under the
influence this time, okay?
It won't be under the influence!
Who's the next victim?
Rest in peace to all the wisps who have died.
I'm gonna be... I'm good now!
I'm a clean...
I'm a clean ghost!
So who would like to volunteer?
Put me in, coach.
Okay, Splagoon.
Splagoo.
Wait, no.
That's bad luck, Splagoon.
You're gonna Splagoo to the pools.
Givvy!
What do you get?
Canapier.
And a canapier.
Oh shit!
Ah!
He has two magnifying glasses!
No!
I guess we'll let's make this three and three.
How about it?
Alright.
To help feed the addiction.
Thank you, Bly's Hunter Dragon.
Why are you hunting?
And the live one, right?
Yep.
Three and three.
That's exactly what I said would happen.
That's exactly what I said would happen, isn't it?
What
do we do, you guys?
What do we do?
Nothing has changed.
Absolutely nothing has changed.
Shoot?
That's okay.
I've felt this before.
uh he didn't yeah he didn't beer he didn't have one so now
it's just two two all right i choose you spla go it
worked you're looking a little scared there mister
it's super effective Don't do it to me.
Careful now.
Splatoon.
Your luck, Splatoon.
Don't play the lottery.
We got some cigarettes.
Your luck, Splatoon!
Two live, three.
Third shell live.
Team mail.
Team mail, activate.
He has the knife, I know.
But he also has a useless item because I got rid of all my
stuff.
So he only has the knife.
Eat the first two?
Smart.
So now it's what?
That's 2-2, right?
50-50?
I think it's live, but it's fine.
Oh!
It wasn't live.
Oh, come on, this is so un...
Don't...
Sayonara!
Oh,
it's so good.
We hardly...
We hardly knew you.
We hardly do ye.
You were so gone to the afterlife.
I'm not laughing.
I'm crying.
You can see my tears.
I'm not.
There's no time for jokes.
Sorry, I'm still crying.
My cries just sound like laughing.
It's so sad.
Just gone.
I'm a ghost too.
It's just gone too soon.
Sorry.
I'm not laughing, it just sounds suspiciously like I'm
laughing.
Alright.
Actual LG.
So that one was so short.
Again, I'm not under the influence.
I'm not even listening to music.
I don't even care about EDM anymore.
I'm a change.
I'm a... I only listen to shoegaze.
Who is our victim?
Not victim.
You're gonna win.
Oh, Shalada Brew!
I volunteer.
Burns.
Michael.
I volunteer.
Dumb a bug.
How about we combine your names?
The Mickle.
Michael and Lovebug together makes the McLove.
Don't sue me.
Oh, come on.
50-50.
Alrighty.
He's gonna...
Wait, well...
Oh, no, it was live.
Okay.
I wish
I had the knife.
You okay there, ma'am?
When he, like, holds it up to himself with such a despair
look on his face, it's so funny.
Okay.
Alright.
He didn't use any of his stuff, which kind of sucks.
Two and two.
Are you winning, son?
Oh, yeah.
He's got all the good items.
What's up with this?
Third shell blank.
The clubbing is what happens in a McDonald's bag.
It looked like you came from the Powerpuff Girls.
What are you talking about?
I look nothing like a Powerpuff Girl.
At least one live in the first two.
Yeah.
What was it?
It was 2-2 though, right?
There are literally bubbles.
Don't say that.
I always wanted to be buttercup.
Then I'm next.
I was four for this one.
2-2-third blank.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah, if you don't use the inverter, you're dead.
I know, I'm trying to think how to use, when to use it.
Yeah, and he can see his shots, I know.
I think I'm just gonna shoot him.
We're Miklovin!
Yippee!
What have I got?
Cell phone.
Polarizer.
Why do they always give him a knife?
Two and three.
All skill by the way.
I know.
Oh!
Damn, we just got rid of...
Wait.
Two, three, one, three.
Second shell blank.
I wish you had told me where the live one was.
And so this one's blank, for sure, right?
Oh my goodness.
So this is the...
It said the second one was...
Or wait, right?
Yeah.
no wait wasn't it the third one it said wait i'm so confused
i can't remember oh everything all the all the past games
are blending together yeah
thought it was the third second is blank it was the second
okay okay it said second okay thank you guys
well we know it's blank
Screw it.
Take him out, but he's gonna use his medicine.
It's okay though.
They're all blanks!
The rest of them are blanks!
Nice.
Ooh!
Okay.
Ta-da!
Three and four.
Three live, four blanks.
Blank.
I don't think it's worth.
Alright, 3 and 3.
I'm gonna check it again.
Because he takes the medicine, if he fails, he'll die, so...
But I don't think he's gonna fail.
I think...
I'm nervous.
Is he not going to take the medicine?
She didn't take it.
Wait, but...
This is the blank, though, isn't it?
So...
This is the blank one, though.
Yeah!
Me!
Should have taken your medicine, Bozo!
We're McLovin!
This is why you always take your meds, everybody.
Unless they make you a little...
Well, those aren't...
You know, that was the game.
You know, that's fine.
Four and four.
Oh no, he's got medicine.
Let's see what we got.
Four and four.
The phones are always hard when it's so many bullets.
fifth show live round okay thanks I guess I guess
2 3
4 5 but
he's gonna It's gonna heal.
Careful now.
Swap the cases.
If I...
Yeah, if I...
I think I have to risk it for the biscuit.
Like, there's only...
I can only risk it for the biscuit.
Because even if I get it wrong, I still...
die!
I must eat it!
I.
My name is Raiden, Entoya, whatever his name is.
You killed my family and made me eat gumpowder.
Prepare to die.
Sig,
Sig, Sig, Sig, please.
Sig, Sig, Sig, Sig, Sig, Sig!
Cigarettes!
No!
Two and three.
Come on!
Why would you do this?
It's basically 50-50.
Yeah, he has the combo.
The wombo combo of the glass and the inverter.
It doesn't matter.
Whatever he- whatever it's- if it's a blank.
It doesn't matter!
Folks, we gathered here in the dingiest, the dingiest
bathroom on the whole planet.
But you know what that bathroom still had?
Love.
And bugs.
And Michael.
And you know, that's just all that matters on this.
Hell of an earth.
No matter where you are.
No matter.
No matter how the odds are against you.
You have love.
And on the other side of that coin is hate.
Now eat this!
Bastard!
But you'll never take me down!
Ah!
At least I shot you before I died!
Oh man.
GG everybody.
At least I beat the first game.
Oh my gosh, I feel myself already addicted to this game too
much a little bit.
GG.
bug i think i think that was actually my last game careful
she's a hero
this is fun this is a good time this is pretty fun i think i
could gamble would you guys want to gamble a little bit more
with your lives would you guys would you guys volunteer some
more to gamble your lives away by my hands go thanks for the
juju Yeah?
I have to fix something on here.
Hold on.
I just want to double check you're not allergic to coconut.
No, I don't think I have any allergies.
We live and die by your orders, boss.
Shining diamonds.
You're all my shining diamonds, truly.
Aren't you allergic to eggs?
Well, like, kind of?
I don't think...
Actually, I've never gotten...
Only if I eat eggs in a certain way, do I...
do i do i get a headache sometimes make us ghost mint i
ain't of no ghost no it says i ain't afraid of no ghost raw
no if i eat like regular scrambled eggs i get a migraine or
not a migraine well sometimes a migraine it depends thank
you for streaming even though you said you weren't feeling
great earlier I was having a rough day myself, but your
streams are always fine, so thank you.
Thank you!
Yeah, I don't know.
Just like some things that haven't been working in my favor.
But it was a really good weekend.
So.
But I still eat eggs anyway.
I don't really care.
I like eggs.
I'm gonna eat them.
I ain't afraid of no ghosts.
I don't put salt in my eggs though.
I can eat scrambled eggs if I eat them with ketchup.
But I can't eat them by themselves.
That's why I don't think I'm allergic.
I think it's just my brain.
It's weird.
Yeah.
How many ghosts do you ain't of?
What's your favorite style of egg?
Scrambled.
With ketchup.
High greens are awful and very weird.
Let us take a look for you, boss.
Thanks, Mateo.
You're us.
We're the Tagu!
Oh, seven to all the fallen wisps.
Let us honor our fallen with these sick beats in the
background.
You would have loved this one, Karva!
The wisps are dead.
The whips are dead.
Oh.
They died.
They're not... alive.
They died!
On the dance floor!
The wisps are dead.
Dead.
They died.
On the dance floor.
They're never coming back.
We have to call their family.
Who's taking care of their cat?
It's you.
The wisps are dead.
are dead, dead, dead!
How did they die?
They died from dropping to the speed!
Thank you guys.
Anyway, I'm done with that.
How do I leave here?
I got an achievement for listening to the song.
Do you know a way out?
I'm just gonna...
Uh...
Oh, hold this game, you're so right.
Oh!
There we go.
Thank you.
This was so fun!
I want to play it again.
And win the double or nothing.
Can we get a bust in today?
I was just thinking that!
Same time next week?
Always.
Same time next week.
Old game on SimSail?
Caller Neighbors from Hell.
It's a click and point puzzle game.
Oh.
Let me write that down.
Thanks for the suggestion.
Also, Dottons, thank you.
David, thank you.
Oh, sorry.
David Tai-Tai-Tai-Tai-N-A-M-P-P.
Can't believe she...
Can't believe the maid hates Omar rice.
I never said that.
Thank you for the one stream.
Also, congrats on your concert.
Thank you, Tri-Francess.
Wasn't there to watch live, but saw a clip of you singing.
You deserve every light stick for your lovely performance.
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
Hold on.
Let's move over to the talking screen.
Talking screen.
Subman, hope you're having fun getting shot.
Yeah.
I beat judgment and I think that you'd love it.
Imagine a more serious Ace Attorney where you beat up
people.
Where does the Ace Attorney come in?
Where does the Ace Attorney come in in that situation?
Oh, hold on.
Let me exit out the game.
We'll put on some more lively music.
Give me a second.
Well, maybe not.
I want to listen to some dry hairs.
Jazzy.
There we go.
Did I like dance?
Got some shots before MGSCon.
Fox die.
We're like, Fox Jedi.
Oh, I'm still down here.
Fox Jedi.
Yeah, oh my gosh.
So I had, I went to, I had my virtual vacations concert.
Oh, this past weekend And I went to Anime Expo a little bit
Let's see The concert was so fun It was It was It was very
I've never Sang before Like live like that Or rather You
know, because I was haunting the theater Usually like in the
past it's always been digital if I was sitting at an event
and so it was the first time for me and I was so so nervous
I like the screenshots of the back rooms with the PSG wait
wait not wait the MG why did I say the PSG I can't read
I'm like the PSG
with the MGS3 filter.
Yeah, this is what MGS1 does to people.
Like the PSG.
Yeah, the room was so yellow.
Like I, and I was just sitting, it felt like, you know, when
you wear those, like, what, the polarized sunglasses, it
felt like I just had those on, like, not, like, the whole
time.
It was so weird.
But I got to meet Bao and I got to meet Pandora and they
were so sweet.
And it was fun.
So we had sound check, obviously, right?
And they had us, like, listen to the music.
We had, like, on little ear monitors so that we could hear
the crowd, but also hear the music and ourselves.
But, you know, it's so different when...
you do the sound check without people and then when you do
the soundtrack with people because like in the middle of the
show i was like oh my gosh everybody's cheering so loudly i
can't even i can't hear the bgf i can't hear the background
music i couldn't hear the instrumentals so i was like during
geek and i borderline i even got like off timing i was like
i was like oh my gosh i can't hear anything it was so bad
and then also i couldn't hear myself at some point So I was
like, especially when I sang Stellar, Stellar, I was so
nervous for that song.
Like, I can't even, I was holding, I printed out the lyrics
because I wrote some notes on them for stuff.
And I was like holding it in front.
And my hand was shaking so much.
I looked like a little shaking deer.
And I'm just like, like, with my shaking hand, I'm like,
And I was like, and I was like shaking so much.
I could barely read the lyrics.
I was so nervous, especially for that song.
Because I really wanted to do it justice.
But, because it's like my favorite VTuber song ever.
It's so, so good.
But I also couldn't hear what I sounded like.
So I was like, I probably am botching it.
But it was good.
It was still fine.
I even, I was so nervous.
I forgot my the the backstage part was like upstairs So I
even forgot my lyrics upstairs.
I had to go grab them So It was funny.
I was like can I go can I go I forgot something can I go
grab it It's the middle of the concert
It was so silly I but that face you have when you went afk I
know for everybody to just see I'm very sorry gone fishing
for real but yeah and and then after the end we did an
encore which it wasn't super it was kind of last minute
where they asked me before if I wanted to do this with Bao
and I said sure or rather I said I'm not sure because I
didn't want to I didn't want I didn't know if my throat
would be okay so I was like ah how soon do you need me to to
tell you and they were like um like maybe like a week before
I was like okay I can I can see how my throat is i can see
how my throat is before in a week like a little week before
and then everyone shouting she hates us was great it was so
funny it was so funny and then we were we were we were in
backstage and we were like heard everybody going you want to
say you want to say it we were like Why is everybody saying
that?
But it was fun.
It was really fun to sing it with Bows.
To have...
And also, none of us knew each other's set list.
So it was really neat that basically we were hearing
everybody's set list for the first time too.
Yeah, the USA Mint flag.
I had my friend go and grab it for me And then she brought
it backstage and I signed it
So it's funny Yeah Speaking of Celis, can we see what they
were?
For me?
Or for everybody?
Because I don't know what everybody's was.
I'm sorry But for me It was Love Determines And then Eke and
I borderline and then Stellar Stellar and then Kahen Sanmen
Mix Oh Boyeru Uta and then New Romantic Sailors which that
was the Stellar Stellar and the Kahen Sanmen Mix song were
the two songs I never sung before so it was really fun yeah
there is someone Chris uploaded a VOD on YouTube so he can
watch the whole concert Oh, yeah, and then break stuff, of
course.
Of course, of course, of course.
And I was...
You're upstream.
Thank you, Misk.
Is that you, Misk, insanity?
Wasn't that AX?
If I saw some cool clips of virtual vacation on Twitter, it
looked like such a blast.
Hoping this is the first concert of many.
I hope so, too!
I hope so too.
Um.
Uh.
Oh, yeah.
We were kind of nervous because, like, you know, the, the, I
think the concert was announced first.
But then, like, the, there was so many things happening that
night.
There was the, the Dodgers game that was happening.
And then there was, like, some other concert that was
happening that night.
And so we were just like, oh, man.
Like, us backstage, we were like, you know, hopefully.
like people you know and i felt bad because i was just like
oh there's probably people that got tickets for the concert
but wanted to go to the to the dodgers thing i kind of
wanted to i wanted to go to the dodgers but i'm really glad
people filmed it because it looked so cool such a packed
weekend it was it was uh but um the clips of the game look
so awesome like with the the drone show i wanna i've never
seen a drone show before i was like It's the coolest thing
ever.
Yeah.
But.
Jonathan, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
So.
It was really cool that, you know, that happened.
The drone sui sei.
Oh, there was drone sui sei.
Drone gura.
Drone pekura.
They were all so awesome.
But.
Yeah.
I want to see the Dodgers game.
But I have to remember guys going to virtual vacation.
Thank you.
Yeah, so...
Yippie!
Kresu!
Wow, thank you for filming everything!
Before the show, when they picked me up from the airport,
one of the staff people was just like...
They got it.
They were like, do you know Kresu?
And I was just like, oh yeah!
I've seen their clips before.
They were like, they emailed us and asked if they could
film.
And I was just like, oh, good.
Then there will be a...
There will be a film of the concert.
There's a spider on the wall.
I think you noticed me looking at him.
He stopped walking.
He walked.
What was I saying?
Rain of spiders!
He's going to the maid dress.
Actually, I think he lives inside.
Oh, no.
There, he stopped again.
I'll stop talking about you.
Get out of here.
He's not a big guy.
He's a small guy.
It's my midnight snack.
Yummy.
Um.
But, uh, yeah, so, so if, you know, pick one or the other
for the concert or, you know, or either any of the other
events that were happening at, at the, in that weekend, that
day, that Friday, which there was so much going on.
Thank you if you went to virtual vacations.
And if you didn't go, I hope you enjoyed whatever event you
went to.
And if you weren't at the event at all, I hope you had a
good weekend.
AX was so fun.
It was a little overwhelming.
It was kind of me being like, I'm gonna walk around for a
little bit.
And then...
Oh, I have to meet with people.
Oh, I'm meeting with this person.
Blue Archive booth.
I'm meeting this person.
Got to meet with this person.
Blue Archive booth.
So...
Did you end up talking to Sumidae?
No!
I don't think I would...
Even if I recognized you right off the bat, I wouldn't have
either.
I saw her in the industry lounge and that's kind of where
like people go to like like relax, you know I saw like her
staff taking pictures of her.
She was like holding something up and they were taking
pictures of her In fact, I should wait, she doesn't have a
Twitter I should I should see if they posted it To not have
interactions so much.
Yeah, so I would have left her alone, but I definitely was
there and I was like Who is that?
Who is that?
And then... And then... It dawned.
Oh, is that Katsumi there?
In my... Actually, it's so funny because... Well...
Actually, I can't say that.
I'm sorry.
Well, actually, I can say this.
I can say this.
someone I know was walking with her as well and they waved
at me and I was just like oh hello and I was in the industry
room to like meet with someone too so so my friend waved at
me and
and it like made her look at me too so I was like now I'm
like
Maybe she could see ghosts a little bit.
Maybe she sensed my presence.
But no, there was so many people and so much life force to
suck.
So it was just kind of like so much energy.
I basically became physical for the weekend.
Almost.
I think you could probably see me.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Doki mentioned, shut up!
No, my heart went to Doki.
Suck.
Yeah, I go.
Delicious life force.
Do you have a plan to open up a PO box?
Mmm.
Not right now.
I'm sorry.
I don't really have a good way to get one.
But maybe in the future, I can have some weight for that.
Any plans you were able to make at AX through network?
It's kind of hard because I met some people that I have met
in the past.
the industry but it was kind of weird to be to like kind of
you know go up to some people and be like hi i'm a ghost
would you like to work with a ghost though actually the only
people i really talked to was the blue archive booth but
we'll see what happens not that like i'm not like super
talking with you know but i just kind of introduced myself I
got the info right information wrong about the game it's
five dollars not four oh it's okay
I'm ghost I was like when I was like I'm ghost they're like
you're ghost vtuber I was like uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh I'm
ghost I'm ghost I'm ghost vtuber
Oh, maybe one day.
Fingies crossed.
No.
But other than that, it was so much more meeting with, like,
other things, too.
But some cool stuff is cooking, I think.
So, I'm trying.
I've been kind of feeling frustrated.
A little bit.
Well, not frustrated.
Like, it kind of goes back to why I was frustrated at the
beginning of the stream.
because sometimes like I'll be offered things but I can't
accept them because I'm waiting on other stuff and so it
feels like I'm just kind of stuck in I mean I'm a ghost of
my mom always stuck in limbo but now I'm stuck in limbo with
this as well so it's just kind of like it feels frustrating
because it feels like I can't get I can't do what I want to
do and I'm having to turn down other things because of
having to wait and so it's just been a little
frustrating and it's kind of of my own making it's sorry I'm
being so vague but I don't want to spoil stuff so it's
stalled and blocked it's frustrating Yeah, because there's,
it's like, you know, people will be like, do you want to do
this?
And I'm like, yes, I do.
But I can't right now.
And so I'm trying to figure out how I can do stuff because I
don't want to keep turning down stuff.
I don't know.
It's a good problem to have to sit at the very least.
Yeah, I guess that's fair.
It's better to get stuff than not get stuff.
That's so true.
But I think once I'm able to finally progress, you'll
understand, then I can kind of explain in better detail, and
you'll probably understand better why it's been a little
slow for me.
So don't get me wrong, there's lots that I want to do.
I'm just waiting on other people.
and other things.
that's what's been the holdup on stuff.
So, you know.
What has been slow?
What are you talking about?
What do you mean?
For me, I feel slow.
Sorry.
I'm trying not For you to know that I'm...
I don't want you to tell that I'm crying.
How do you know?
Ugh.
Sorry for...
Being such a downer at the end of the stream.
I just don't want to disappoint you guys.
So...
And I...
I don't know.
You know, I...
Kind of was like...
For a while now.
For like... I don't know.
Well, I mean, I've only been around back since like...
For a couple months, but...
You know.
Even still, I just...
Wonder if...
I'm ever doing a good job or not.
so
because you know after heaven and all I you know it's I
thought I might give it all up and
so I want to make sure that if I I'm back now and have the
chance I want to do it properly and do a good job
So...
That's all.
It's just been bugging me.
Um, for a little while.
But, you know.
I also...
use this to keep me motivated.
You know, you know, I'm too stubborn.
When I feel like, if I'm not doing a good job, it makes me
be like, yeah, we'll do a better job, dummy.
Thank you guys for your nice words.
I appreciate it.
No.
Anyway.
I try not to talk about this kind of stuff because...
It's only stuff I should worry about.
It's only stuff I should worry about this all.
Thank you.
Next, thank you for the Uncle Soba!
Don't worry, do what makes you happy.
Thank you.
Sorry, my nose is all stuffed now.
And you're gonna be like, what nose?
I already know.
Already nose.
But, um...
I will keep working harder.
Yeah.
So...
And I will be patient.
I will be...
I will be patient.
And keep waiting.
Hopefully.
But I am cooking up some fun stuff, I think.
Again, it's just...
Some of the waiting.
It's also just, you know.
Like I said.
It's frustrating to be like, I can't do something because
I'm waiting.
It's like the worst feeling.
Not being able to do something cool or fun because you have
to wait.
Ah!
Even if you were a grocer.
Maybe I should have gone to be a grocer.
Would have been way less pressure.
Oh, fix either here or look, I see you.
Goodbye, thank you.
Uh, not you'd hate it.
I've done it before.
And probably it would be more pressure on my wallet, though.
More pressure on my wallet, probably.
I hate retail so much.
I know.
customers the customer is not always right how would you buy
all the mgs merch you have expensive hobbies i know
but it's okay i've given up my hobbies before
and then you know for all the for all the retailers all the
office workers in the world You can watch my streams and
hopefully, you know, you can feel better and decompress
after a day.
And I can relate to your struggles.
I can relate too much.
My co-workers are the worst part.
No way!
That's not supposed to be the worst part.
It's supposed to be the customers are the worst part.
The office worker survivor, Minto.
Got you.
Sometimes it's both.
Yeah, sometimes.
Alrighty.
I think I'm going to go to bed now.
Honestly.
I have no idea what I'm doing this week.
Oh.
I don't really know what I'm doing this week.
There will be stream this week.
Tomorrow too.
Shady.
I'm sorry.
I killed you.
Much love.
It's always a fun time when you stream.
Thank you for that, Kusuba.
Thank you.
Boons.
No.
No, Boons.
Love watching your streams after work.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
And Vod Watchers and Lurkers.
Hello, if you're watching.
If you got this far.
Uh.
I really enjoyed your streams and the fact that you enjoy a
lot of the same things I do.
Keep doing amazing things.
Thank you.
A requshu.
Okay.
Okay, let's bust in.
Let's get rid of the sad music.
No more sad.
Tomorrow I'll do lots of work.
Where?
Oh, bust in.
Bust in.
Yeah.
Do you think it's gonna be too loud?
Let me turn it down.
Sure.
Bada!
Is it too low?
I don't wanna get caught by the coffee, right?
Bada, bada, bada.
Bada.
Let me tell you something.
There's something weird.
Sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Oh.
I got the part wrong, but it is.
If you're seeing things, sleep it in your bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
An invisible man sleeping in your bed.
Oh, let me tell you something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why stem, by stem, by stem by stem, by stem, by stem, by
stem.
Stim bust, stim bust, stim bust, stim bust, stim bust, stim
bust Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good,
feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, yeah,
yeah, yeah
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good
Freaking Ghost Man!
Let me sleep in your bed.
Phew!
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good!
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Makes me feel good.
Feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel
good, feel good, feel good!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Thank you for a buckshotting with the reeeeee!
It was so fun!
Oh, seven to all the fallen wisps who became real wisps.
Yeah, yeah!
Thanks for watching, thanks for hanging out with the bee!
Have a good rest of your night, and I'll see you next time I
see you!
Bye bye!